[Music]
it's YouTube week here on the Rubin
report Karin stron is a men's rights
activist a youtuber and a mother of
three
Karin welcome to the Rubin report hi
again I'm doing well how you doing this
morning I think I lived yes but you know
check back later yeah well let's see if
you get through the hour you got like a
little like allergy situation or
something yeah you may have to mute me
as I sneeze my head off you never know
but yeah well that'll add that'll add
some charm to this for the people who
are just gonna get to know you for the
first time there you go easy the letter
take a benadryl and then be like this
the whole time so that also that also
could work you do what you got to do
let's put a ballot all right so I'm very
excited to talk to you because we've
sort of been bouncing around in the same
world for quite some time but this is
the first time we're ever talking
actually so first off men's rights
activist I thought men were privileged
and evil have I been mistaken this whole
time I'm pretty sure you never actually
really thought that um at least not the
evil part a lot of people do think that
men are privileged but they do happen to
be marginalized a number of significant
ways and a lot of those issues that they
face are actually institutional they're
in law they're in policy um and in the
institution's best practices and so
they're sort of written into the system
in a in ink they're not sort of the
ephemeral social discrimination that
most phones complain about today that
happens to women um you know there are
policies out there concerning domestic
violence that essentially train police
officers to just arrest the man unless
it's really egregious unless he's got an
axe in his thigh or something like that
right you move the man you don't remove
the woman so um this is really what I
deal with that a lot of those things
were implemented
and through feminist lobbying and
feminist efforts at getting laws
rewritten getting policies rewritten and
things like that and so sort of over the
course of my investigation into all of
these problems I went from being a non
feminist to being antagonistic toward
feminism to being now out and out I
would actually call myself an
anti-feminist now um that that would be
the priority um you know men's rights
activism comes second to that in a lot
of ways so that's where I'm at right now
yeah so I definitely want to dive into
some of the the feminine of the history
of feminism and a bit about your
evolution and all that but before we do
that can you give me a couple more
examples of the sort of what you would
say or is the systemic discrimination I
get it there's things in like domestic
abuse or in probably divorce cases where
generally they're going to be more
lenient with the woman than they would
be with the man that kind of thing can
you give me a couple of those before we
go any further well I mean a lot of them
overlap I mean with divorce in so many
cases you'll have a woman who she'll
have a lawyer on one slifer and a social
worker on another side of her saying
just tell the judge you're scared of him
you don't even have to say he hit you
right you'll get a restraining order
he'll be out of the house he won't be
allowed to see you or the kids six
months from now when it's revisited then
the judge will say well the children are
stable in the sole custody of the mother
and therefore there's no reason to
change that it would cause further uh
people in the children's lives so so now
therefore you have the house because the
residents of the children and you have
sole custody of the children and you you
know the father might have limited
access to them no form of custody
whatsoever so I mean it really is this
sort of part of the gamesmanship of
divorce is the abuse of some of the
protections that have put in place
specifically to protect women from
domestic violence so you have these
overlap
problems um and when you look at some of
the rhetoric coming out of organizations
like the National Organization for Women
who you know sort of they've described
men's rights groups or fathers rights
groups as an abusers Lobby I recall
reading an article written by a man at
the National Organization of men against
sexism that essentially said that if the
mother doesn't want you to have custody
you should just back off and let her
have her way because anything else is
abuse and um if you're a man who's
actually dealing with an abusive
ex-partner who has custody of the kids
what do you do um in in a society where
so many of the attitudes at least in
terms of judges and lawyers and social
workers and all of these people who
really have a lot of control over your
life
um if they're embracing those attitudes
how do you how do you deal with that how
do you protect your children how do you
have any kind of decent life so yeah I'm
curious when did you first realize that
this was important to you as I said at
the top you're a mother of three
children I think you're divorced am i I
am is that correct yeah did that
specifically have anything to do with
this or was your awakening before then
or well I mean my I always kind of knew
a lot of this stuff you know the stuff
you hear about women's oppression and
and particularly about domestic violence
beings with a male on female the problem
um I always knew that was just [ __ ]
II because in my experience at that
point you know throughout my you know
20s and early 30s I knew more men who
were battered by their spouses than
women who know about better by then
theirs
yes oh yeah um and they don't tend to
talk about it um they just kind of or
they shrug it off right you know they
come in with a big bruise on their face
and they're just like oh I pissed her
off right and
are there numbers on this that you know
of because I feel like certain people
are going to be listening to this
because it almost sounds a little
unbelievable I'm not I'm not saying it's
I'm not saying it is unbelievable but I
think a certain amount of people are
gonna go wait a minute how often is a
man showing up to work with the bruise
because he was hit by his wife right oh
I think that a lot of people would be
very very surprised um there is a
meta-analysis it's a huge project they
they analyzed 1,700 different studies on
domestic violence on partner violence
and they found that most of it's
something they would call common couple
violence and most of that is reciprocal
um so it's two people beating on each
other and and it usually doesn't
escalate and it just has to do with
stress or conflict or you know people
just you know they have a moment of
weakness and they push someone or shove
someone or whatever right right
santé and those generally I mean most
domestic most credible domestic violence
researchers would say that those require
sort of counseling or public health
approach to them rather than a criminal
one because they do tend to de-escalate
over time people generally learned how
to live with each other and get along a
little bit better your mother-in-law is
not always visiting you're not always
losing your house right and those these
situations where these kinds of things
come up um then of the other cases the
other half those be unilateral violence
and some of them are cases of somebody
just losing their temper and it wouldn't
necessarily follow a pattern of abuse
mm-hmm but others are a smaller
percentage of those are what you would
really see in a movie like enough or
sleeping with the enemy where you just
have this ongoing pattern of coercive
control and violent control of a partner
and manipulation and all of those things
mm-hmm they found that in about 70
percent of those cases it's the woman
doing it to the man Wow yeah
so when you're looking at really
egregious things like she she's mad at
because he's not doing what she wants
and so she pours boiling water on him
while he's while he's sleeping right um
and I don't know that this is because
there's anything intrinsically horrible
in women I mean there I know that there
are women out there who have a vicious
streak a mile wide but um I think it's
more about the fact that we don't ever
really socialize girls in the way that
we socialize boys in terms of hitting
the opposite sex
I mean you grew up as a boy you were
told it's never okay to hit a girl right
specifically a girl yeah we don't tell
girls this about boys um we tell them
don't hit but we don't ever make a big
deal about it if they hit a boy and in
fact you can see girls on the playground
they'll hit a boy and then they'll say
well you can't hit me back because I'm a
girl I mean they know they have carte
blanche to do this right right and then
you and then occasionally you'll see a
video I can think of one particular one
in the New York subway you probably saw
it where this girl kept whaling on this
guy and basically was like you can't hit
me you can't hit me then he finally hit
her after she taunted the hell out of
him and and then everyone was pissed at
him yes oh of course of course they're
like you can go on YouTube and just look
at social experiments you know just use
the search terms domestic violence
social experiment woman hits man
whatever you find that when the woman is
abusing a woman is abusing a man in
public people laugh they think it's
funny um they might look a little
uncomfortable some of them like oh this
is none of my business but they ignore
it um in one there was actually a guy
walking by who smacked the guy on the
back of the head like don't like help
her out even on the guy right and then
you turn it around and you have a guy
even just getting menacing with a woman
he hasn't even necessarily laid his
hands on her yet and you already have
people just sitting at the alert like
when when is the point where I have to
intervene mm-hmm and then when he does
lay his hands on her they intervene and
in one of these ones uh you you
literally had this guy he was
just he I guess he took her by the
shoulders and he was shaking her and
yelling at her and saying why were you
texting that guy or something and and
three men just come from three different
directions and tackle him and he ends up
on the ground was all scabby and and and
he had to yell we're filming were
filming this is a social experiment
because they were gonna kick his ass
yeah do you see some of this as sort of
the phrase that I've been saying in
every every week now which is the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
that these people I think have some good
intentions so for the example you used
at the beginning where the woman the
woman sitting there with the social
social worker and the lawyer and they're
saying just say the threat of violence I
mean I'm sure there are many women out
there and and probably some men too that
never physically got hit by their spouse
but did have legitimate lived with a
certain amount of legitimate credible
threat all the time so these people are
trying to protect them now that doesn't
mean it's actually working but I think
that the intent is there perhaps I
actually think that number one I think
that it's not generally probably like
that I think that the more combative a
lawyer in particular manages to turn the
situation into the more money he's going
to make so if if it is not an amicable
agreement to you know terms of custody
and all of those things then if she
makes that move that's not only going to
cause huge problems for him it's gonna
make him resent and it's gonna turn the
entire thing into a long combative
process and all the lawyers cash in this
is why you have sort of bar associations
associations of family law attorneys um
sometimes improperly funding Lobby
efforts to quash alimony reform bill
bills and things like that and shared
parenting bills because they stand to
lose money the more peaceful a divorce
is the less money these lawyers make and
social workers are often sort of
ideologically driven in terms of you
know maybe they took gender studies
maybe they took women's studies they
bought the whole thing
butl they believe that men are the
oppressors women are the oppressed um
they believe and this is actually a
theory within feminism that all-female
female violence against a male partner
is responsive violence even if it is
initiating violence even if she's
hitting first and hitting consistently
and hitting constantly it is what they
would call violent resistance against
his oppressive controlling behavior that
they just assumed that he's engaging in
wow so that's like some real like the
man has original sin kind of thing so no
matter what he does even if he does
literally nothing the woman sort of has
carpod to do whatever she wants
well and and so people people who
actually kind of get sucked into this
type of ideologies
whenever you feel really passionately
about an ideology and I'm no different
you're no different or a way of thinking
or an idea um you want to spread it you
want to convince other people you want
to do do those things and so a lot of
these people who get really passionate
about it they end up in politics they
end up in journalism they end up in
media they end up in social work they
end up in the law right so they end up
in all of these places where they can
influence the system in order to bring
about whatever utopian goals that they
have in mind where you know the men are
no longer the oppressors and everybody
is equal and I don't even know what the
hell they want but um so that that's
really I think that that's probably more
likely to be what's going on there the
laws I believe were uh signed into they
were passed into law and the policies
were passed as policies or approved as
policies probably with good intentions
on the part of politicians yeah the
people who wrote those don't necessarily
have the best of intentions yeah and I
always feel like when we're discussing
this or it doesn't have to just be about
feminism or men's rights or any of that
stuff but that I try not to demonize
everyone's intentions because it seems
like a lot of my ideological opponents
are doing that often and I try not to do
that but you're what you're saying is
yeah then you get lawyers mixed up in it
and you get
everybody else that wants to make a dime
and then next thing you know a law that
was passed for for a potentially good
reason ends up being pretty crappy how
much of this do you think is just sort
of our expectations about men and women
in general so for example if we took
like you know Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie and if we heard this afternoon
that Brad Pitt was beating her for the
last year he would be you know kicked
out of Hollywood he would be his career
would be ruined bah-bah-bah if we found
out that Angelina Jolie was abusing Brad
Pitt for last year it would be it would
be a running joke amongst everybody it
would be on the front page of the post
would have some funny picture of him etc
etc how much is just about what we
expect a relationship to be like between
men I don't think I don't think that's
anything new um I think that that these
are deeply ingrained these attitudes
towards all of this and and one of the
biggest tricks that feminism has ever
pulled were the biggest cons is that
they claim to be against those attitudes
and those norms I guess if you will um
but they are masters of exploiting them
right so essentially you I mean what is
domestic violence legislation that
specifically protects women against
their male partners what does that say
about men and women it says that men are
strong and when women are weak that men
are dangerous women need protection
these are not new attitudes there's
really old attitudes and so they've
essentially taken every every little
thing that sort of may be part of our
biological wet wear and then it gets
reinforced by by society and
acculturation and those things they've
taken all of those things that are age
old that existed forever and they've
completely exploited them to their own
to their own ends and all the while
claiming that they are dismantling all
of those norms and it's it's absolutely
ridiculous it's yeah it's the plain [ __ ]
when you really think about it so I
started asking you this and then we kind
of we kind of skirt it away so when you
wake up was it was it really a personal
thing that was happening or was it just
from reading or something you saw or
what the wake up when I actually decided
that I had to do something um that was
uh that was actually during my divorce I
had just separated and I was beginning
to realize just how easily I would be
able to completely destroy my acts like
absolutely demolish his life it would
have taken very very little effort on my
part and I was one of those people that
I wanted to sort of even bend over
backwards to be fair with him and you
know so I we had sat down and we had
written out a temporary separation
agreement you know that would last one
year that assigned custody and gave him
generous access whenever he wanted it
and all of these things and that where
he would not owe me any child support
because I was a higher earner at the
time and he was the one that was moving
out he needs to be the one getting on
his feet and that we would revisit it
after one year and my lawyer looked at
me and said I want to slap you for
signing this like wow how could you sign
this you could get so much more and I'm
like why would I why would I do that
why would I do that and and I had chosen
my lawyer because he had uh half of his
practice was mediation huh so he wasn't
even a family law attorney he did most
of his family law cases he went took
three mediation and so it was I was like
I know if anybody's not gonna be
combative it's this guy right it's gonna
be a nice easy process right but even he
was like you know I can't believe you
would sign away so many of your
entitlements and I'm like okay and wait
so did you did you sign it as you wanted
to or did you let him influence you oh
god no I was I was essentially okay
here's how it's gonna go does this sound
fair and he looked at it and he said
yeah no that sounds fair like that like
we were just I mean he was angry because
it was a unilateral decision on my part
but you know we were gonna divorce but
um he wasn't pleased with me or anything
but
he was pleasantly surprised at the fact
that I would um even just offer him like
to say okay here's what I think we
should do and he was like okay that
looks that looks fine right cuz he had
been through a previous divorce and I'd
been through some stuff right and he was
expecting the worst and then while I was
um while during that year between when
we separated and when we could actually
start finalizing the divorce and and
finish the whole thing um cuz in Canada
you have to be separated for a year
unless you have some kind of pressing
cause to split up and I stumbled across
a men's issues website it was pretty
hardcore I mean like a lot of people say
a voice for men is like just so
misogynistic and angry and all of this
right but this website it was called the
spearhead it's not no longer online it
was really hardcore and I just stumbled
in there by accident and I'm like
talking to a lot of the commenters there
and reading the articles and they the
articles usually came with lots and lots
of citations to research and things like
that and that was I think when I
realized just how far into the system
all of these kind of kooky ideas these
eccentric ideas of feminists about how
men and women are had actually gone
right they they just kind of got their
hooks into the whole thing and not just
in laws which are actually easier to
deal with in policy because laws laws
need to be debated they need to be voted
on by electors entity' --vs they need to
pass constitutional challenges right
there needs to be some kind of public
notice that these laws are under debate
but policies often come through ad hoc
committees yeah and you know advisory
councils of hand chosen individuals who
all are self-proclaimed experts and who
are not elected and then you know some
bureaucrat who's also not elected says
well this looks good
and now it's best practices and those
are often much harder to uproot so once
I realized all of this um that was when
I was just like you know somebody's
gotta actually do something about this
so yeah all right so you you go down
this rabbit hole you find this
information that you feel is is good and
valuable and real and you have your own
awakening did you immediately decide
okay I'm gonna be public about this how
quickly did you say alright I'm gonna
start making some videos I'm really
gonna start pushing and putting myself
out there um well first off uh you know
I used to fell out of it I was I went
through a period for about six months
where I was working 50 55 hours a week
so I really didn't have a whole lot of
time to do other things but um once
things calmed down in that regard
my the guy that I started dating he said
oh there's this interesting because he
knew we talked very very clearly and
openly about all of this kind of thing
and no less because he had had his own
experience with a breakup and losing a
child
um losing complete contact and access to
that child and having no rights
regarding that um that he said here's
this place you know that you can discuss
this stuff it was the men's rights
subreddit and so I went there and I
started commenting and got lots and lots
of I guess they call it karma um lots of
upvotes and things like that and people
started recommending that I should be
you know writing somewhere other than
the common threads on reddit so I
started a blog and one night while I was
at work my boyfriend emailed without
asking me emailed my very first blog
post to Warren Farrell no I don't know
if you've heard of Warren Farrell but
he's Oh best-selling author about 10-15
years ago he was for one of Forbes top
100 thought leaders in the world
um he is I don't know whether he
considers himself a men's rights
activist now but he's written several
books father and child reunion used to
be big feminist um the myth of male
power right got booted from the National
Organization for Women for being a bad
feminist and all of that because he
tried to present the male side of things
right and so this was a big big name in
the sort of the whole area and I was so
mad at him and then half an hour later I
get an email from Warren Farrell saying
that was really great
right and that egged me on and it
spurred me on and and what got me doing
videos was all of the accusations from
feminists that I obviously am a man you
are obviously a man probably a fat ugly
neck bearded one who can't get laid
because no woman would think the way you
do and so I just came out on camera and
then I got popular I got really popular
from there right so when you put
yourself out there for that moment
you're suddenly this has been a theme
with all of the people that I'm
interviewing for YouTube because I don't
think that necessarily any any of us are
the only person out there thinking the
things that we're thinking but there are
a select group of us that put ourselves
out there and then we you know we get
some of the accolades and some of the
crap for doing so when you put yourself
out there and you got all that nice
feedback but of course you're getting
some bad stuff too how does that affect
you in general just being part of the
social media part of this the comments
all of that stuff because I think for
everybody I've been talking to there is
a certain toll that it takes but it's a
lot of pressure um you know you always
have this this pressure especially when
you're when your audience is is
comprised of men who have you know often
been you know had their lives turned
upside down or they've they've been
wrongfully accused of something or or
what some of these things that these men
have gone
through that have contacted me are
really really egregious they're just
absolutely devastating and so there's
this responsibility that you feel to not
want to say anything that might upset
them mm-hmm um even if it's a truth that
needs to be told you definitely don't
want to say something in an insensitive
way that would upset them I absolutely
have no problem offending feminists I
you know I get the drive-by comments I
get them calling me names I get them
occasionally sending me threats um does
not bother me it doesn't I mean I
thought that kind of thing never has
bothered me um and and a lot of insults
from them you know like you look like a
man and obviously I know why you do this
cuz you're ugly and you just the only
way you can attract men and all kinds of
really sexist things right like things
that have you said that about a feminist
that you're ugly and you know you can't
attract a man that's why you're a
feminist right right right right
but somehow they're they're the tolerant
ones you know they're they're the tyrant
I mean there is an aspect of that you
know I was just discussing this
yesterday with somebody online and you
know a lot of people on my side of
things do the men's rights or
anti-feminist anti sjw side of things
have made the claim that you know sjw's
do way more you know we do the insults
and the the vitriol and and the threats
and and things like that they do way
more than we do I don't know if that's
true because there is that difference in
how the impact that it has witness when
it's a right what you would consider to
be a righteous target mm-hmm and when
it's someone coming at you or one of
your friends or colleagues or associates
so I don't know I don't I you know I
would have to actually see some hard
data on that in order to be able to
really justify saying that they are less
tolerant than you know the people who
watch my videos or whatever right right
we we all
want to believe that our audience is the
most tolerant I think I've I think I've
built a pretty tolerant audience which
is why I can tell that you know I got
Clinton supporters I got Trump
supporters I got Gary Johnson supporters
I got anarchists and and everything but
yes everybody picks their thing to be
offended over I'm curious I've noticed
that when sometimes I get criticism
people say well Dave you're a liberal
but you spend a lot of time criticizing
the regressive left does that mean
you're you're giving the right a free
pass and I my argument back is well I'm
trying to clean up my house everyone
attacks the right left and right pun
intended
everyone turn oh yeah turn on the daily
show or any other show they're always
attacking the right okay we get it
that's fine but I'm trying to clean up
my guys I don't know if it's working or
not but that's what I'm trying to do do
you ever feel the same thing that if you
spend so much time doing what you do
that you might ultimately be giving an
e-zpass to the to the people that would
be doing things to women that that you
wouldn't want done um you know honestly
I don't I don't know that that is
necessarily even possible I mean I think
we all get that sick feeling in our gut
when we see a man hit a woman that just
isn't there when we see the opposite I
think that we all sort of have a sort of
natural failsafe in terms of egregious
abuses against women um you even look at
something like I don't know if you
remember this the Egyptian woman in the
blue bra oh yeah yeah right and here can
you explain that for people that okay so
was it was in Egypt there's a big
protest the police for coming in beating
the protesters there were like hundreds
of protesters dozens of them being
beaten and there was one woman in a
burqa and she was being beaten quite
severely and then her garment fell open
revealing this blue bra and everybody
was outraged the UN expressed concern
that the Egyptian police were now
targeting women specifically the
Egyptian women came out of their homes
for the first time sort of on mass and
held a protest march
chanting dragged me stripped me my
brother's blood will cover me all of
these things right and it was all about
the fact that this one woman was beaten
so severely and and I'm looking at this
film and I'm trying to divorce my
emotions from it and really see what's
going on and what I'm seeing is all of
these men getting the [ __ ] beat out of
them and one about maybe eight feet away
from her getting a much more severe
stomping by police and the moment her
her garment falls open and the cops
realized that there's actually a woman
under there because they had problems
with men dressing as women because when
you dress as a woman you're immune from
that kind of thing um in a lot of cases
right that kind of violence that's
targeting males specifically there's
about the targets women more than males
but not to say that the women in burkas
in the Middle East aren't getting
subjected to all kinds of violence of
course there is specific types of
violence that will target men more than
women and when were more than men and
police violence tends to target men more
than women and what happened when they
noticed that she was a woman was they
immediately moved to cover her up and
one of the costs was sort of in the
process of lifting his foot up to kick
her and another cop pushed him away and
then they carried her out of the cameras
view mm-hmm and I'm thinking okay so and
everybody else is still getting beaten
right so she was actually once they
realize she was a woman they stopped
beating her and I'm thinking and
everybody is somehow losing their minds
over this right so I really don't think
that we're in danger of that kind of
thing that kind of insensitivity towards
things that affect women in in negative
ways I think that we're I think that
we're actually never going to get to the
point where we're as sensitive about
negative impacts on men as we are about
women no matter how much men's rights
activism there is no matter how much
anti feminism there is I don't think
we're ever going to have that same
sort of brain stem rationale in our in
our system that tells us that harming
women is is wrong and harming men yeah
it's okay so is that do you think that's
really ultimately just evolution because
as you said before there's a gut
reaction if you saw a man hit a woman
there's a gut reaction the men were the
hunters and gatherers the women were
taking care of the home there is just
something built into our DNA our cosmic
ooze at this point that you can you can
explain as much of this as you can in a
rational sense but you can never
overcome what is sort of built into us I
I do think so um like when when you look
at it's not so much the hunter-gatherer
part of things although that does
necessitate you being willing to subject
your men and your young men to higher
levels of risk of injury and death than
you are and that makes perfect sense in
terms of you know reproductive
strategies and and things like that you
keep you keep your uterus as safe um
because that's the future that's your
children right and a woman is not just a
woman she is a woman plus every child
she will ever bear right so there's that
calculation in our DNA and then on top
of that it's the warrior aspect as well
uh you would not be able to convince men
to bash each other's brains out to
protect women and children if men had a
natural impulse toward sympathy empathy
compassion toward other men the way they
do with women and children you just
wouldn't be able to do it that would
have had to have been selected out in
order for men to play that particular
role as long as they have which is six
eight ten million years long before
we're even hominids right so you're so
you're acknowledging you can't sort of
beat our evolution in your argument but
you can do your best within the
constructs of intellectualism or
something problem a little bit I hope
yeah the hope I guess that's that's the
hope really quick backing up to the
woman in Egypt one of the things that
I've seen in the last year or so related
to feminism is its utter failure in
mainstream feminism to defend all of
these women especially across the Middle
East but but we see plenty of them in
Europe too that are that are in these
burkas and that are basically covered
head-to-toe you can see a slit of their
eyes I've seen videos I've seen videos
in Saudi Arabia of them being beaten in
malls and public places by strangers
they can't drive separately they have to
be out with a male that's accompanying
them all of these horrible things and
this is something that modern mainstream
feminism seems to utterly utterly ignore
so in the case of the woman in Egypt
they ignored the woman in Egypt in the
burqa until that event happened then
they got outraged but they didn't seem
to care about her life before that what
what do you make of that um well I don't
I don't think that they are necessarily
because I I would actually take the
approach of it's not necessarily
something that we should be sticking our
nose into and I know that it's gonna
sound like cultural relativism but it's
not really cultural relativism is that
most people aren't educated about other
aspects of cultural practices and
traditions in within Islam that if we
were to liberate women without touching
the male half of the equation we would
end up with something really really
really awful um you know like when a
woman in under Sharia the woman has the
right to a bride gift
it's called damar or Maria sometimes and
this is her money um she holds any
property that she owns her husband can't
touch any income that she earns her
husband can't touch he is the provider
the entire provider for the family
unless between the two of them they
negotiate something different so she has
this it's a paper debt for the most part
so it might be fifty thousand dollars
right
um that he has pledged to pay this is
her security this is what she gets if
anything happens to him he dies or
whatever out of his estate is first paid
this the remainder of this gift right
she might get $4,000 in gold coins to
begin with and the rest of it is on
paper and she would call it in at any
time if she divorces with cause she gets
all of the the entire payout plus
alimony um
and she has an entitlement to be
supported by his income alone and so she
doesn't if she has income she doesn't
even need spend it on herself so of
course she's gonna need his permission
to go out and work because working
requires day care and working requires
transportation and working requires all
kinds of other expenses it costs money
to work there's an investment involved
there and if those become necessities
he's responsible for paying them right
so they have to negotiate something like
she would have to say to him maybe maybe
he might not give permission no matter
what but I know several Muslim Muslim
couples in Canada who do live by these
customs it's not law here but they'll it
they choose to live by these customs and
they negotiated and he said yes you can
go out and get a job um I'm confused
though are you
sorry good he says I do want to pay for
all of the household expenses but if if
you need daycare to work or if you need
new clothes to work or if you need a car
to work I would like that to come out of
your pay and not mine I don't want to
have to get a second job to subsidize
your ability to go out of the house to
work right so those kinds of things a
lot of people don't realize that um and
actually one of them he's from Lebanon
he told me because he just contracted to
marry and he just signed the dotted line
on his bride gift on the on the Maria
which was I think in his case it was
$35,000 um he said that if his wife
chooses to when they have children
because he's responsible for feeding and
sheltering the whole family she can
demand a wage from him for breastfeeding
their own child right so I mean there
are some things that we in the West
haven't look
dad that if we say to women you don't
have to live under the authority of your
husband you can go out and get a job if
we don't do something to amend his
obligations his financial obligations to
her he's gonna end up having to take a
second job in order to pay for her
driving to and from work and pay for her
wardrobe and pay for the daycare and all
of those things and she has to just keep
all that money to herself right so I
don't think I think that these things
definitely need to change I absolutely
do I think feminism I think you could
you guys need to stop encouraging
feminism to go in there and stick their
noses in and because if they do it
they're gonna bung it up so if so okay
okay so so you're not fully down with
everything that you just said you're
saying you're just saying this is a
thing that exists and and that feminism
as it exists is not the thing to fix
this it's not the solution now it is not
so then then what is the solution for
the average person that I look I think
that if you see a woman in a burka I
would venture to say that ninety nine
out of a hundred times that is not
ultimately her choice this is not a
person ultimately living their authentic
self because if it was if it wasn't
about empower you know power over the
woman you'd see a lot of men in burkas
but you know you see women in burkas so
what what is it that the outsider can do
I get why you're saying feminism as it
is would screw it up because they have
they'd flip the power dynamic and then
completely that's no good - but what can
we do when we see you know as Bill Maher
says if you cover up all your women and
you hang gays that's fertile ground for
terrorism because if you're not getting
laid and you can't see women and blah
blah blah so what do we as Outsiders
that care about these people these women
what do we do well I think I think we
need to start caring about everybody and
not just the women I think we need to
start caring about the 95 percent of sex
workers in Afghanistan who are boys we
need to start worrying about the 95
percent of child labourers in
Afghanistan who are boys many of them
working to support their mothers in
they're sisters so you have to actually
take a holistic approach and look at the
entirety of the problem I remember
reading an article years ago where they
were interviewing women in Afghanistan
who were furious at the West they said
what you're doing right you are giving
all of this help and all of this
education and all of this Aid and all of
this support to women and girls and you
are abandoning our men and our boys and
what is it that you want do you want
them to all sicken and die and then it's
going to be up to the women and girls
alone to rebuild our country we need to
actually take a look at the entire thing
right and that means that we need to
acknowledge that there are some benefits
to being a woman under Islam there are
some benefits to being a man there are
some disadvantages some of them very
extreme to being a woman under Islam and
some of the exact same thing to being a
man that these are two groups of people
who have different sets of rights
privileges obligations and entitlements
and that they are those two sets of how
things are done were developed in a
complementary fashion so when you [ __ ]
with one side without adjusting the
other then you end up with a massive
massive source of injustice so what we
need to actually be doing is we need to
be caring about all people in the Middle
East including the men including the
boys when you hear I mean you think okay
so you see a woman being beaten in a
burqa well you know last I checked the
the US military wasn't firing soldiers
for defending those women but they were
firing soldiers for defending an
eight-year-old boy who was being
repeatedly raped night after night right
right and I get what you're saying look
if you treat the women better if you if
the women have your equality that comes
with more equality for the men these two
things are totally
totally symbiotic okay so all that said
what do you make of what seems to be the
strange relationship that is mocked all
the time on YouTube the strange
relationship between feminism and Islam
and because I think the best example of
this would be in Germany and Cologne the
New Year's attacks where it was known
that these were migrant men we don't
know that they were doing these attacks
in the name of Islam they happened to be
Muslim but they were new people in a
Western society that hadn't been
westernized and almost all almost all of
the left-wing media and certainly all
the big feminists that I know of online
all were attacking basically attacking
the women for not understanding they
refused to tak either the men themselves
I could say and I only I don't blame an
entire religion I believe the men
specifically that did this and the
ideology that they did it for but it was
almost everything backwards it got
Richard Dawkins into a lot of trouble
because there was that feminism I'm sure
you saw that cartoon the feminism
Islamism thing that's are going to be
God retweeted what is that what is that
the most liberal ideology is what
feminists have put at the top of their
oppression Olympics you know I I don't
know you know I think I think maybe they
just want to ignore all of that
inconvenient stuff that's going on
within Islam um because they really I
think their main focus is to bash their
own men that's that's really what they
want I mean you even who wasn't was a
Jess Phillips or something
she said that Oh Cologne what happened
in Cologne it's no different than your
average Saturday night on Broad Street
yeah right you know and I'm like what um
they really they don't want any of the
focus taken off of their own men I don't
think that they see any there's a huge
will to power within feminism within
movement feminism institutional academic
scholarly feminism there's a a
a striving toward power a striving
toward control a striving - and they
don't care what's going on over there
they want you look at they care much
more about the number of women in
Congress than they care about the
everyday problems of the 80% of women
out there who are not feminists right or
they're not careerists they they aren't
they don't think like these women do
because you know we don't have big
exciting careers we have jobs mm-hmm and
when you work at a Tim Hortons or a
McDonald's or cleaning somebody's
toilets it's inevitable that you would
rather have less work force
participation if possible rather than
more which means that you need strong
families and you need a strong
partnership with a man who can help pay
the bills and run the household and all
of those things and so you don't see
marriage as subjugation of women you
don't see marriage as your own
enslavement you don't see any of these
things the way these women see them
these women they're mostly elitists
they're mostly highly educated middle
class upper middle class women this is
always being the case all the ways the
suffragettes and they have a completely
different set of values and when they're
looking at the men in their lives
they're seeing men like Bill Clinton
they're seeing men like you know one of
the most telling things that I think
experiences for me was sitting next to
Naomi Wolf wanna panel and she said well
I don't know what world you're living
and none of the men I know none of the
people I know among my friends could get
away with denying their or the women I
know could get away with denying their
husbands access to the children and I
said but you're wealthy right I mean
like when you have a net worth of three
million dollars right you can afford as
a man to reengage the system constantly
constantly to reinforce your rights and
your wife knows this your ex-wife and it
was this and so she doesn't mess with
your access
doesn't mess with your custody right she
was so offended by me saying she was
wealthy she was like how dare you you
don't know anything about me I am NOT
wealthy right yeah yeah she's not
wealthy rich is married to a Clinton
speechwriter like what universe is she
living in right I was a waitress at the
time yeah what does that tell you really
about that type of thinking because
ultimately what you were able to offend
her with was telling her that she was
rich somehow that now yeah that is
actually more offensive acknowledging
that you've become successful which is
what most of us would like to do right
most of us would like to be successes
but by you saying you've become
successful so the system now is able to
work in your favor depending on how much
money you have which everyone no one
doesn't acknowledge this that was the
most offensive thing to her oh well
because because it's an indication that
she has privilege right and when you're
you know when you buy into the whole
progressive stack thing you know when
you have privilege you go to the back of
the line and you get to be the last
person to speak yeah but not only that
um she wealth is one of the most obvious
privileges out there I mean we have a
smirky woowoo concept in feminism called
male privilege right male privilege oh
it has its downsides and it backfires
and it hurts men too and you know we
need to get rid of male privilege
because of not just because of the ways
that harms women but because of the ways
it harms men right okay
would anybody say this about being
wealthy right I would argue that being
wealthy is the one privilege that's
actually legit because it's complicated
right it's acquired so you don't have to
do any mental gymnastics to actually
prove its existence you don't have to
say oh well money hurts people in this
way but really it's a privilege to have
it know um no it's the only real
privilege that there is and she's
soaking in it and Madge you're soaking
in it Oh
and so it's like that is something that
unless she flat-out denies it there's
there's no way to defend herself against
that yeah so speaking of the whole
social justice movement regardless of
whether we're talking about black lives
matter or feminism or whatever there is
for all of us and this has been a
through-line for all the people I'm
talking to this week for a YouTube week
for all of us that are fighting this
idea of being you know judged as groups
and not as individuals and all of this
stuff and as someone that puts your
stuff out there to fight this what do
you think is the best way for the
average person watching this to fight
these ideas give yourself moral
permission to think the way you already
think this is really the big the big
thing that I have because when I talk I
talk about this freely in public openly
the moment I came out under my real name
I had to inform my bosses of what I did
to prepare them for any kind of a lot of
phone calls demanding they fire me or
something or a picket line or something
um so that at that point when they
seemed completely unfazed for the most
part like completely didn't bother them
um and to two of them one of them was a
woman expressed extreme interest
the woman was almost in tears saying I'm
just so grateful there's somebody out
there doing this Wow an unflattering out
why she was so emotional that it was
because her son was on trial on felony
harassment charges against his he was 18
he'd broken up with his girlfriend
because he caught her cheating and the
only evidence in the case at all was the
hundreds of texts and emails and
voicemails and things like that
that she had made to him that he thank
God he kept them all right because it
went to court and the moment that these
things were presented to the judge that
judge just dismissed the case said like
why are you even like how did this even
make it into my courtroom um she was
stalking him but she couldn't felt like
she couldn't tell anybody that her
family was going
through this um at the time but she was
so just like so emotional and then she
told me about it afterwards after he had
after the case was dismissed and I was
just like oh my god like what a horrible
thing to go through and so essentially
every time I go to that you know grocery
store and I'm standing in line I get
chatting with someone anybody asks me
what I do I just come out and tell them
I'm at anti-feminist right and I just I
don't act ashamed about and I explained
they're curious I explained why then
what I do they say oh ya know my
brother-in-law is going through
something like that and there you go
like it they they don't they're quiet
about it they don't talk about it maybe
they feel ashamed thinking that the
system is is wrong or or unjust or
whatever um and that's because the
mainstream media all it wants to talk
about is how great feminism is and and
all of this stuff right um and they get
keep like mad in terms of you know the
Guardian and places like that and a half
PO and and things like that they get
keep like mad in terms of what is
presented to the public
that's the Overton Window is what's
presented in the mainstream media mm-hmm
so all I have to do is shift that a
little bit me and people like me and
then all of a sudden people find
themselves going you know I always
actually kind of thought this way but I
always was told that it was wrong and I
guess maybe it's not and that sort of
the job that we have to do just convince
people they're not bad people for
thinking the way they think yeah I love
the phrase you said there which was give
yourself the moral authority it's like
all these people's yeah all these people
are always trying to moralize us well
night why not moralize yourself and push
your ideas so alright so I have to end
with with one final question which is
you were once interviewed by my former
boss Janke over at the Young Turks and I
guess the question that is the burning
question on most people's minds is did
you ever make him that ham sandwich no I
haven't you
but I do have plans um it won't just be
ham it will be several meats source this
many many types of wonderful things that
grow in the ground harvested at their
peak freshness rest between two lightly
grilled pieces of fresh-baked bread and
then I will wrap it up and put it in the
mail for [ __ ] well that is very exciting
and I hope there is a video of him
opening that well caridy really it was a
pleasure talking to you i knew i was
going to enjoy this one and i fully did
so I want to thank Karen's drone for
joining me on the Rubin report for our
big YouTube week and you can check out
her channel at youtube.com slash girl
rights what and the link is right down
below
[Music]
you